[Musique]
parce que je suis attaché à notre modèle
social et parce que je crois dans la
démoc
ratie c'est sûr votre réforme sur le
texte du Parlement fruit d'un compromis
entre les deux assemblées que je suis
prête à engager ma responsabilité
c'est sous une Marseillaise et les huée
d'une partie de l'Assemblée nationale
que la première ministre Elisabeth band
s'est exprimée cet après-midi devant les
députés elle a déclenché l'article 49-3
de la Constitution pour faire adopter le
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
sans vote à la mi-journée Emmanuel
Macron avait convoqué un conseil des
ministres en urgence pour autoriser ce
recours ou 49.3
on était en majorité relative pour le
pack autour du président de la
République et pendant plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines on a cherché à
négocier à élargir cette majorité pour
obtenir un accord sur ce texte des
groupes politiques comme les
républicains qui pourtant s'est engagé à
l'occasion de leur campagne à une
retraite à 65 ans avec soi-disant des
mesures beaucoup plus ambitieuses n'ont
pas souhaité
soutenir le texte et donc nous n'étions
pas en capacité d'assurer que le texte
passerait or ce texte est fondamental
c'est un engagement du Président de la
de la République et donc il est apparu
nécessaire au président et à la première
ministre puis à la majorité de passer ce
texte en 49 3 les groupes d'opposition
déjà annoncés le dépôt de plusieurs
notions de censure je crois que c'est
d'abord une trahison démocratique qui va
rendre encore plus illégitime ce projet
de loi qu'il était déjà beaucoup parce
qu'il est rejeté par l'écrasante
majorité des français par la totalité
des organisations syndicales et donc le
gouvernement continue dans sa stratégie
qui est de faire un passage en force
émotion de censure évidemment parce que
c'est constitutionnellement la riposte
aux 49-3 et j'espère que elle sera votée
le plus largement possible et je pense
notamment du côté des républicains de
son côté l'intersyndicale doit se réunir
ce jeudi soir pour décider de la suite
du mouvement de grève
le département des Yvelines est entré en
situation d'alerte pour les usages de
l'eau et concernés par l'arrêté
préfectorale le centre du département la
raison la situation exceptionnelle de
sécheresse en période hivernale les
faibles précipitations ont entraîné une
absence de recharge suffisante des
nappes 85 communes sont concernées cette
situation d'alerte entraîne par exemple
l'interdiction d'arrosage des pelouses
et jardins potagers entre 11h et 18h ou
encore celle de l'alimentation des
fontaines publics ou privées en circuit
ouvert les autres zones scènes sud-ouest
et sud-est sont en situation de
vigilance et mithèque Lançon nouveau
centre d'essai véhicules le groupe
installé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux a
investi 10 millions d'euros dans ce
nouvel outil l'équipement principal la
plus grande cage de Faraday de France
elle est dédiée aux essais de véhicules
et aux tests de grosses systèmes et
consiste à vérifier la capacité d'un
matériel électrique ou électronique à
fonctionner de façon satisfaisante sans
provoquer de perturbations il se lançait
le défi en septembre dernier collecter
des fonds pour financer l'opération de
trois enfants malades mercredi 15 mars
les maires de Villepreux et Le
Port-Marly révélé le montant obtenu par
l'association élu du cœur le magasin
Leclerc de Bois-d'Arcy organise son job
dating il se déroulera le 25 mars
prochain au sein même de l'enseigne plus
de 50 postes seront proposés poissonnés
boulanger ou encore pâtissier
possibilité de déposer sa candidature
sur le site recrutement Leclerc avant de
se rendre directement en magasin mais
aussi de se présenter spontanément sur
place
[Musique]